what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alba and I'm John Humphrey so we're
gonna watch this video that was sent
over to us
and I heard it's pretty cool Mayweather
vs McGregor spoof epic fail and surprise
knockout we're gonna go watch the
Mayweather fight tonight at a friend's
plays ringside I've been really looking
forward to this fight I've seen all the
press conferences actually I have I
don't even really follow MMA or boxing
but I've seen a few of McGregor spice
and seen a few and Mayweather spice I'm
super amped for this fight I am like
it's a guy who doesn't really watch this
[ __ ] I know a lot of the anticipation
for it and I know a lot of the history
behind it so I'm pretty excited for it I
have seen McGregor play video games with
Conan and I've heard talk about Lloyd
Malin this is from growl Studios is good
you should subscribe to these guys let's
sing it poor dude let's find out
[Music]
[Applause]
well Instagram don't lie what are you
doing go time patty-cakes
somebody's old has got to go oh he's
totally corner McGregor super voids and
claymation your [ __ ] [ __ ] Mayweather
boy [ __ ] [ __ ] how they tough talk in
the world of ya mismatch oh my gosh I've
talked plenty about this with people
this claymation animation was pretty
[ __ ] funny yeah yeah whatever there
he just kicks smashes is like money for
da leaves a foot in his face that was a
great spoof of who these two personnel
yeah you can see McGregor kind of
flipping this away chain going [ __ ] this
yeah
I love the press-conference moment learn
about 30 kick because people seem to
favor McGregor all the time you know
well I think it's just hard coming from
that perspective like I know you have
such a broad range of ways that you can
mess dudes
ya know whereas Floyd as a you know
boxing is just more of a restrictive
sport and there are lots of rules and
technicalities and stuff I guess I could
share with you guys who I think would
win honest answer no idea because
there's so much to this I mean McGregor
is an MMA fighter champion both in two
divisions and Mayweather 49 and oh this
is his arena
this is his field but there's a lot of
things to that I know about these guys
McGregor he when you see these press
conferences especially the last one
McGregor is like hungry to win and it
feels like a lot of people are betting
more on McGregor I'm not sure about that
maybe just the circles I run in in
California where everyone's like I think
McGregor is gonna win but Mayweather
this is his missus his ring he's 49 and
oh and it's a different type of sport
there's different rules to it he knows
how to dodge too and he's probably
faster than McGregor the thing is I feel
like McGregor would have to land a
knockout punch to the guy's face but
Mayweather knows how to dodge man I feel
like Mayweather probably has like a 51%
more chance
yeah he's older - he's like late forties
man he's much older McGregor is like 29
years old yes this is a fascinating
fight to me because it does seem like a
real humdinger of a matchup because you
are la yeah this dude is like McGregor
sounds like he clearly has a huge
reputation in turn like he's Champa -
divisions like he's an incredibly good
fighter but also Floyd has the streak
and and now I'm wondering you know how
is age gonna factor into this and like
it's easy I feel like it's easy to think
that McGregor might win because McGregor
had we know that he has a wider array of
skills so that to me says like oh you
know he might be able to think on his
feet a little differently but Floyd's
been doing this sport forever and
McGregor is coming over to it you know
Mayweather also I don't think can take a
hit as well as McGregor can that's what
I feel like could be an edge because
greggers seems like he can just take a
pound it really feels like you know what
I feels like Rocky 4 yeah except no
one's really an underdog here yeah
exactly
but it's cuz like Mayweather the boxer
and then you got who is rocky in this
scenario and then McGregor is like Dolph
Lundgren yeah I mean he's the beef
muscle guy who doesn't really have the
speed or as much experience and being a
skilled boxer and Ivan Drago strengthens
you can knock out rocky and that's what
McGregor has to you know Mayweather
knows how to keep still standing he
knows how to dodge he can do probably
that rib punch and they were talking
about two great body shots
so one he's probably seen this before
yeah see the thing is I feel like this
is one of those fights that will kinda
to me come down to who wants this more
yeah because the drive to unseat the
king I know she's king you know is a
huge Drive but also the drive to show
that young whippersnapper whose box yeah
just is big I I feel like McGregor seems
like he wants it more and he does like a
lot of visualization and stuff and it
has to pan out for him and I get a vibe
about him on this yeah I feel like
that's where I would lean whoever wins
I'm not gonna be surprised yeah this
doesn't determine for me who's the
better fighter this boxing match because
if Mayweather wins it's like well it's
Mayweather sport I mean but if you put
Mayweather inside of an MMA yeah not
gonna do that so and the thing is I
don't know boxing in and out but having
seen some anime I am sort of like well
yeah I mean you know you've taken away
like half of my capabilities so yeah
maybe he might lose I think a big reason
why people are also going against
Mayweather is because he is 49 and oh
this will be his 50th match he's
supposed to retire again that's what he
does up for every match from retiring he
is rocky never seen Haven rocky is their
personality
there is like loud all about money and
noxious and people I think people don't
like his personality so much he's super
duper cocky and that's all something
reason why we're gonna watch this
because these are the two cockys
fighters going at it yeah you want to
watch what happens when too cocky dude's
throat yeah although in the last press
conference Mayweather was incredibly
respectful McGregor was still saying
like I'm gonna take this [ __ ] down and
all that stuff but Mayweather was super
respectful even gave credit to McGregor
and he was calm and reserved there's two
ways to read that he's taking a humble
approach or he's terrified it's like a
lot innit two ways to take like
Mayweather is now there's this lifestyle
where he can sit atop the mountain and
wait for you know a warrior to come
challenge him and that's how his career
works now either way whoever loses they
both win because they're making so much
money and Mayweather we know is a money
guy who loves to splurge loves to spend
his dollars McGregor is already the
champ of MMA and Mayweather has already
proved himself 49 wins in a row like
when everybody wants to have that
perfect record yeah but 50 you know will
be pretty this it that's the one number
man the old like I don't know I I don't
really know who to sentimentally root
for but I do think like 50 you know
would be pretty impressed this is a VP
it's like as much as part of me wants to
go like yeah you know like come on
McGregor like you got the skills to take
him down I am like that would be special
too oh do if McGregor wins he's the most
feared dude in the world
yeah it's special either way but you
know if do you know would be would be
cool yeah if Mayweather wins it's gonna
be like well that's a ground yeah man I
cannot wait for the match I'm gonna be
at a party with friends I want to just
enjoy my life and I'm gonna livestream
the whole wife thing over your reaction
go outside I'm gonna pick fights with
random people and see if I can beat 50
of them yeah for the white eye runs
better is because he'll do that you know
no let's do a super chat and you can
like to pay me every time I fight
somebody open perfect well you can
subscribe at the real rejects make sure
to check out this guy's original video
we'd have a link in the description box
for it for growl studios growl did a
great job with this video go check it
out
dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram check out our patreon become a
page from a Chuck today join us your
[ __ ] [ __ ] rejects
I had a [ __ ] batch unless you don't
come on over to our patreon I can't do I
that's a drunk eye or adjacent cuz I
can't hold that is i McGregor sound